I think what is probably the
most misunderstood concept in
all of science, and as we all
know is now turning into one
of the most contentious
concepts, maybe not in
science, but in our popular
culture, and that's the idea
of evolution.
Whenever we hear this word, I
mean, even if we don't hear it
in the biological context, we
imagine that something is
changing, it is evolving.
And so when people use the word
evolution in our everyday
context, they think of this
notion of change, that-- this
is going to test my drawing
ability-- but you
see an ape bent over.
We've all seen this picture at
the natural museum, and he's
walking hunchback like that, and
his head's bent down and--
oh, I'm doing my best.
That's the ape.
Maybe he's also wearing a hat.
And then they show this picture
where he slowly,
slowly becomes more and more
upright, and eventually, he
turns into some dude, who's
just walking on his way to
work, also just as happy,
and now he's
walking completely upright.
And it's some kind of
implication that walking
upright is better than
not walking upright,
et cetera, et cetera.
Oh, he doesn't have
a tail anymore.
Let me eliminate that.
This guy does have a tail.
Let me do it in an appropriate
width.
This guy has a tail, so you're
going to have to excuse my
drawings skills, but we've
all seen this.
If you've ever gone to a natural
history museum, and
they'll just make more and
more upright apes, and
eventually you get to a human
being, and it's this idea that
the apes somehow changed
into a human being.
And I've seen this in multiple
contexts, even inside of
biology classes and even the
scientific community.
They'll say, oh, the ape evolved
into the human or the
ape evolved into the pre-human,
the guy that almost
stood upright, the guy that was
a little bit hunchback, so
he looked a little bit like an
ape and a little bit like a
human and so on and so forth.
And I want to be very
clear here.
Even though this process did
happen, that you did have
creatures that over time
accumulated changes that maybe
their ancestors might have
looked more like this, and
eventually they looked more like
this, there was no active
process going on called
evolution.
It's not like the ape said, gee,
I would like my kids to
look more like this dude, so
somehow, I'm going to get my
DNA to get enough changes
to look more like this.
And it's not like
the DNA knew.
The DNA didn't say, hey, it is
better to be walking than to
be kind of hunchbacked
like an ape.
And so therefore, I'm going to
try to somehow spontaneously
change into this dude.
That's not what evolution is.
It's not like-- you know, some
people imagine that maybe
there was a tree.
There's a tree, and on that
tree, there's a bunch of good
fruit at the top of the tree.
Maybe they're apples.
And then maybe you have some
type of cow-like creature, or
maybe it's some type of
horse-like creature that says,
gee, I would like to get to
those apples, and that just
because they want to get
there, maybe the next
generation-- they keep trying to
raise their neck, and then
after generation after
generation, their necks get
longer and longer,
and eventually
they turn into giraffes.
That is not what evolution
is and that's not what it
implies, although sometimes
the everyday notion of the
word seems to make us
think that way.
What evolution is-- and
actually, this is the word
that I prefer to use-- it's
natural selection.
Let me write that word down.
Natural selection.
And literally, what it means is
that in any population of
living organisms, you're going
to have some variation, and
this is an important
keyword here.
Variation just means, look,
there's just some change.
If you look at the kids in your
school, you'll see variation.
Some people are tall, some
people are short, some people
have blond hair, some people
have black hair,
so on and so forth.
There's always variation.
And what natural selection is is
this process that sometimes
environmental factors will
select for certain variation.
Some variations might not
matter at all, but some
variations matter a lot.
One example that's given in
every biology book, but it
really is interesting is-- I
believe they're called the
peppered moth.
And this was in pre-Industrial
Revolution England that these
moths-- some of the moths were--
let me see if I can
draw a moth.
I think you get the idea.
Let me draw a couple of them.
Let me draw a few
peppered moths.
A couple of peppered
moths there.
Let me draw one more.
So most peppered moths, there
was just this variation.
Some of them were-- I guess we
could call them more peppered
than others.
So some of them might
look like this.
You know, they had-- let
me do other colors.
Let me do a white.
So it had spots like that.
Some of them might have
looked more like that.
And, of course, they had some
black spots on them.
And then some of them might
have been-- just
barely have any spots.
You just have this natural
variation.
Like you'd see in any population
of animals, you'll
see some variation in colors.
Now, they were all happy,
probably for thousands of
years, just this natural
variation.
It was a non-important trait
for these peppered moths.
But then, all of a sudden, the
Industrial Revolution happens
in England, and all this soot
gets released from all of
these factories that are running
these steam engines
powered by coal.
And so, all of a sudden, a lot
of the things that once were
grey or white, for example,
maybe some tree trunks.
Let me draw some tree trunks.
Maybe there were some tree
trunks that used
to look like this.
You know, maybe it looked like
a-- maybe it kept a-- maybe
some tree trunks used to look
something like this, and a
peppered moth would
be pretty OK.
Maybe there are some tree trunks
that were pretty dark.
But all of a sudden, the
Industrial Revolution happens.
Everything gets covered with
soot from the coal being
burned, and then all of
a sudden, all the
trees look like this.
They're just completely pitch
black or they're a lot darker
than they were before.
Now, all of a sudden, you've
had a major change to these
moths' environment, and you have
to think what is going to
select for these moths?
Well, one thing that might get
these moths are birds and the
ability of the birds
to see the moths.
So all of a sudden, if the
environment became a lot
blacker than it was before,
you can guess
what's going to happen.
The birds are going to see this
dude a lot easier than
they're going to see this dude,
because this dude on a
black background, he's going
to be a lot harder to see.
And it's not like the birds
won't catch this guy.
They'll catch all of them, but
they're going to catch this
guy a lot more frequently.
So you can imagine
what happens.
If the birds start catching
these guys before they can
reproduce, or maybe while
they're reproducing, what's
going to happen?
This guy, the darker dudes, are
going to reproduce a lot
more often, and all of a sudden,
you're going to have a
lot more moths that
look like this.
You're going to have a lot
more of these dudes.
So what happened here?
Was there any design or was
there any active change by any
of the moths?
Did any of the moths-- I mean,
it looks like a really smart
thing to do to become
black, right?
Your surroundings became black,
and you wait a couple
of generations of these moths,
and now all of a sudden, the
moths are black.
And you might say, wow, those
moths are geniuses.
They all somehow decided to
evolve into black moths in
order to hide from the
birds more easily.
But that's not what happened.
You had a lot of variation in
your peppered moth population.
And what happened was that when
everything turned darker
and darker, these dudes right
here-- and dudettes-- had a
lot less success
in reproducing.
These guys just reproduced more
and more and more, and
these guys got eaten up before
they were able to reproduce or
maybe while they were
reproducing so that they
couldn't produce as many
offspring, and then this trait
just became dominant.
And then the peppered moth just
became-- you can kind of
view it as a black moth.
Now, you might say, OK, Sal.
That's one example.
I need more.
This is natural selection.
It's purported to apply
to everything.
It purports to explain why we
evolved from basic bacteria or
maybe even self-replicating RNA,
which I will talk about
more in the future.
I need more evidence of this.
I need to see it in real time.
And the best example of this
is really the flu.
And I'll do other videos in the
future on what viruses are
and how they replicate.
Viruses are actually
fascinating, because it's not
even clear that they're alive.
They're literally just little
buckets of DNA and sometimes
RNA, which we'll learn is
genetic information, and
they're just contained in
these little protein
containers that are these neat
geometrical shapes, and that's
all they are.
They're not like regular living
organisms that actively
move and that actively have
metabolisms and all that.
What they do is they take that
little DNA, and they inject it
into other things that can
process it, and then they use
that DNA to produce
more viruses.
But anyway, we can do a whole
series of videos on viruses,
but the flu is a virus.
And what happens every year is
you have a certain type a
virus, and they have
some variation.
I'll just make the variation
by how many dots they have.
And they infect-- let's
say it's a human flu.
They infect humans, and slowly
our immune systems, which we
can make a whole set of videos
on as well, start to recognize
the virus and are able to attack
them before they can do
a lot of damage.
So now you can imagine what
happens if, let's say, that
this is the current flu.
Let me do all of them.
They all have these little two
dots and that's how-- and
we'll talk in the future what
these dots are and how they
can be recognized.
But let's say that's how our
immune system recognizes them.
They start realizing, oh, any
time I get this little green
dude with two dots on it's,
that's not a good thing to
have around so I'm going to
attack it in some way and
destroy it before he infects my
DNA and all the rest. And
so you have a very strong
natural selection once immune
systems learn what this virus
is-- and we'll talk more about
what learning means for an
immune system-- that they'll
start attacking these
guys, right?
But flu, you can kind of think
of them as being tricky, but
they're not really tricky.
They're not sentient objects,
but what they do do is they
constantly change.
So what you have is, in any flu
population, you're always
having a little bit of change.
So maybe the great majority of
them have those two dots, but
maybe every now and then, one
of them has one dot, one of
them has three dots, and maybe
that's just a random mutation.
This just randomly happened.
Maybe this is one in every--
I'll make up a number: One in
every million of these viruses
have this only one dot instead
of two dots.
But what's going to happen as
soon as the human immune
system gets used to attacking
the virus
with the two red dots?
Well, then this guy isn't going
to have to compete with
the other virus capsules
for infecting people.
He's going to have people's
DNA all to himself.
And so he or she, or whatever
you want to call this virus,
is then going to be
more successful.
So by next year's flu season
when people start sneezing and
are able to spread it on
doorknobs and whatever else
again, this guy's going to
be the new flu virus.
So when you see this process
of every year there's a new
flu virus, that is evolution
and natural
selection in real time.
It is happening.
It isn't this thing that only
happens over eons and eons of
time, although most of the kind
of the substantial things
that we see in our lives or even
ourselves are based on
these things that happened over
eons and eons of time,
but it happens on
a yearly basis.
Another example is if
you think about
antibiotics and bacteria.
Bacteria are these little cells
that move around, and
we'll talk more about them.
They actually are definitely
living.
They have metabolisms
and whatever else.
And this is just a nice note.
When people talk about
infections, it could either be
a viral infection, which are
these things that go and
infect your DNA and then use
your cell mechanisms to
reproduce, or it could be a
bacterial infection, which are
literally little cells that move
around and they release
toxins that make you sick
and whatever else.
So bacteria, these are what
antibiotics kill.
Actually, I don't think
there's a hyphen.
They attack bacteria.
They kill them.
If you know a couple of doctors
or whatever and you
say, hey, I'm sick.
I think I have a bacterial
infection.
Give me some antibiotics.
A responsible doctor says no,
I won't give you antibiotics
just willy-nilly, because what
happens is, the more
antibiotics you use, you're
more likely to create
versions-- and I want to be very
careful about the word
create, because you're not
actively creating them.
But let's say-- and let
me finish my sentence.
You're very likely to
help select for
antibiotic-resistant
bacterias.
Now, how does that work?
Let's say that these are all
bacteria and you have
gazillions of them, right?
Every now and then,
you get one that's
slightly different, right?
Now in a population of bacteria,
these all will make
you equally sick, and this is
just some random difference in
the bacteria.
Maybe on its DNA some slight
different changes happened,
but whatever happened, these
all are a kind of bacteria.
You don't want to get a lot
of them in your system.
Your immune system can attack
them and fight them off, but
if you get a lot of them, then
they might kill you or make
you sick or whatever else.
Now, if everyone just starts
using antibiotics when they're
not sick or when they don't
really need to in a
life-or-death situation, you
might have an antibiotic that
is really good at killing
the green bacteria.
But what happens if you
all of a sudden kill a
lot the green bacteria?
Well, now the blue bacteria have
the whole ecosystem that
before it was competing with all
these green dudes to get
at all the good stuff inside of
your body, but now he's all
alone, and now he can replicate
willy-nilly.
So now he's going to replicate
willy-nilly, and obviously--
once again, it wasn't like there
was any design, there
was any intelligent process
here that said look, this
bacteria should-- some bacteria
said, oh, I'm going
to be little bit smarter and
design myself to resist this
antibiotic threat.
No!
There's just these random
changes that happen, and
mutations and viruses and
bacteria happen frequently and
these random changes that
happen, and this might be a
one in one billion
change, right?
But all of a sudden, if you
start killing off all of the
people it's competing with, this
guy can start replicating
really fast and then become
the dominant bacteria.
And then all of a sudden, that
antibiotic that you had
developed very carefully to
destroy the green dudes is
useless, and you have
this superbug.
You might have heard
the word superbug.
That's what a superbug is.
It's not like it designed
itself somehow.
It's just that we got very
good at killing its
competition, and so we allowed
it to take over, and we can't
kill it, because all of the
drugs were just good at
killing its competition.
These bacteria just keep
mutating and keep mutating,
and if we use these antibiotics
a little bit too
heavily, we'll always be
selecting for the things that
won't be affected by
the antibiotics.
Well, anyway, I think I've
spoken long enough, but this
is a fascinating, fascinating
topic.
And I really wanted to make this
my very first video or
lecture if you will, on biology,
because if you really
went to-- you know, biology is
the study of life, and we can
talk about what life
is, whether
viruses are living, whatnot.
But if you really want to study
living systems, you
really can't make any
assumptions other
than natural selection.
We could go to another planet
where the creatures don't have
DNA, or maybe they have some
other type of hereditary
information stored in their
cells, or they replicate some
other way, or they're not
even carbon based.
Maybe they're silicon based.
And if we went to that type of
a planet in order study the
biology on that planet,
everything else we know about
biology, about viruses and
DNA, would be useless.
But if we do understand this one
concept, this one concept
of natural selection, that your
environment will select,
and it's not-- you
know, there's no
active process here.
It's just random stuff happened
and they randomly
select for random changes.
And over large swaths of time,
and these are unimaginably
large swaths of time, those
changes essentially
accumulate, and they might
accumulate into fairly, fairly
significant things.
We'll talk more about this
in another video.
See you soon.